Well, look who it is
the Brow...and the Foul
Just ignore them. They’re trying to get under your skin
Aww...how cute is that, Enes
Look at them
They’re like closer than his eyebrows!
Looks like Boogie Cousins has a Boogie Brother
I don’t know though, I’m a bit scared
I mean, with this chemistry they’ve got?
I think they’ve got a real shot at the 10th seed
You know, you talk a lot for someone who has less rebounds than his point guard
Keep your focus, DeMarcus
If you get a technical, you’ll be suspended again
I’m sorry. We’re being rude
I’m actually a big admirer of your game
I love da move where you fake left, roll right, and then get ejected
You know for being a big, whiney pu--
I’ll knock that fancy little stache so far down your throat
you’ll have a merkin on your entrails
Hey hey! Stop it! Stop it! It’s not worth it!
He’s right. Enough of this
King of the Prairie!
While we’re bickering over eyebrows and mustaches,
Golden State is marching towards the championship
Save your energy for the real fight
ARGH! FINE!
To hell with Golden State!
Technical foul!
Oh, c’mon! You gotta be kiddin’ me, ref! For what?
Uh, disembowelment of a referee
which the league is sort of crackin’ down on now...
Do you like it here...in Dallas?
Very much so
Better than Golden State?
Golden State is a ​very​ special place
dear to my heart
But I’m very happy here
in my​ new ​home
But don’t you miss being a contender?
I have a much larger role here
thanks to the graciousness of our Lord
Ah! Nerlens!
I almost didn’t recognize you without your cylindrical hair
It is an honor to present my king
Lord Mark of House Mavericks
Kiss me, child
Thank you, Harrison
We’re delighted to have you here
Please, sit!
Would you like a rib?
No thank you, I’m not very hungry
Oh, child. You can’t come to Texas and not enjoy some ​barbeque​!
Okay
You like the ribs?
It’s very good
They’re Chandler Parsons
...favorite thing to eat when he was here
Oh, you must be thirsty
Where’s the sweet tea?
WHERE’S THE SWEET TEA?
Well don’t just stand there, you imbecile!
Get the DAMN sweet tea!
Now, I know things were...difficult for you in Philadelphia
I’m very grateful for my time at House Sixers--
Oh, stop it
It’s ​dreadful​ in that chamber pot of a franchise
Now, come on
you can be honest with me
I’m not like those other owners, you know
I’m a cool guy
Just a normal
cool
guy
Noted
Well, if I’m being honest
there were a lot of centers and not enough minutes
Frankly, I was very sick of losing
There there, child!
There’s no need to worry anymore
Here in Dallas, we ​never​ tank
Now, chin up!
Aren’t you excited to play with Dirk?
Oh yes, he’s...very good
He’s the greatest
Yeah...he’s great
The greatest
The...greatest
You see, Nerlens
I personally ensure that no one makes light of my Mavericks
Or else...
Or else...what?
Ah! My sweet tea!